casino mogul Steve Wynn resigned
overnight as CEO of Wynn Resorts amid
accusations of sexual misconduct Wynn
said he has become the focus of an
avalanche of negative publicity The Wall
Street Journal first report of the
allegations last month vladimir duthiers
of our streaming network cbsn is here
Vlad good morning good morning
one day after that Wall Street Journal
report came out when announced he was
stepping down as the RNC finance chair
the report detailed winds alleged
decades-long pattern of sexual
misconduct as the head of the casino
Empire he built this is uncork for
decade Steve Wynn has been a Titan on
the Las Vegas Strip
stand up Steve but after the 2016
presidential campaign he also set his
sights on Washington Steve is always
calling he's always got advice right
Steve the longtime business rival and
friend of Donald Trump served as the
Republican National Committee finance
chair until his resignation last month
after the Wall Street Journal published
accusations that Wynn pressured
employees to perform sex acts and in one
case forced a manicurist to have sex
with him he allegedly settled with her
for 7.5 million dollars while you visit
when Las Vegas you don't miss a thing
his resignation from Wynn Resorts came a
day after the Las Vegas review-journal
admitted it held a story in 1998
alleging Wynn pressured a server at one
of his hotels into sex
when allegedly told the woman it was
because he wanted to experience sex with
a grandmother the Las Vegas
review-journal is currently owned by one
of Wynn's rivals sheldon adelson raising
money isn't so much the core of what I'm
doing last year Wynn spoke to CBS this
morning about his RNC role and his
company I'd like to be known as a guy
that can design a building and as close
to his employees the editor of the Las
Vegas review-journal and a Nate Olsen
spokesperson have said publicly a dulce
did not have advance notice of the story
published Monday Wynn is facing
investigations by gambling regulators in
two states he has called the assault
allegations against him preposterous
Matt Maddox the current president of
Wynn Resorts will take over as CEO
it is quite a shift given that he's
considered like the founder of modern
Las Vegas he took a very small casino
the Golden Nugget and turned it into a
behemoth and that's what we have now
with I'm still processing that line
wanting to have sex experience sex with
a grandmother I don't even know what
that means is that me neither
all right thank you